[Music]
today
i'm cooking hearty food recipes with the
generous helping of warmth comfort
and indulgence it's honest food with big
and satisfying flavors that really grab
your taste buds and makes no apologies
so when you want to welcome your friends
or family back home after a nice long
walk or an exhausting football match
these are the recipes to do it with this
is my ultimate hearty food
first up a hearty breakfast of smoked
haddock with spinach baked eggs
that is beautiful for lunch the ultimate
comfort of a hearty creamy tomato soup
that's delicious serve with rich and
delicious welsh rabbit
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast to another level
[Music]
and my youngest daughter tilly joins me
making beef and ale stew with mustard
dumplings
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
followed by a scrumptious pear and
ginger galette
[Music]
three delicious full-bodied comforting
meals breakfast
lunch and dinner starting with a hearty
breakfast
of smoked haddock and spinach baked eggs
smoked haddock one of my favorite fish
delicious
highly sustainable packed with protein
lightly smoked
there's not a dye smoke there's a big
difference see i've got that bright
yellow tinge
so much better next baby spinach
it's a spinach that's very young full of
zinc great flavor
little teaspoon volleyball knob of
butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach but it's
going to disintegrate
almost by two-thirds but i'm cooking
spinach in butter
i open up the top of my peppermill so
the pepper becomes almost like sort of
cracked pepper lots of fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tarragon it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart
pick off the little buds from the stalks
keep hold of these and grateful when
you're making the tag and vinegar
red wine vinegar tag and stalks in chop
the tarragon
into your creme fraiche a little
seasoning
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with havoc
incredible this mustardy herbie creme
fresh will work equally well
partnered with grilled chicken the
headache's starting to flake
because it's smoked lightly cured it
cooks so quickly
you're creme fraiche it's nice
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie
but as opposed to putting pastry on top
the eggs are going to bake on top so you
got this wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off now
crack your eggs around the outside just
a little twist of pepper
get the remainder of your cream fresh
and put a little dollop
in between that adds richness to the egg
whites
into the oven at 180 for 10 to 12
minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs bake
together i can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
in professional kitchens chefs refuse to
use the top of the spring onions but i
love that nice dark green flavor
it's less harsh than the white the smell
of baked mustard
you can't beat that
is beautiful spinach is almost melted in
with a hat up
and now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
wow my ultimate hearty breakfast
smoked haddock and spinach baked eggs so
packed with protein and iron you'll be
raring to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
for my ultimate hearty lunch and dinner
you need some hearty ingredients
here's a more in-depth look at some of
the key ones you'll need to buy
made from roasted malt hops water and
yeast
stout porter was the preferred bevy of
london's river porters in the 18th
century
but this rich bitter tasting beer is
linked with food
goes way back too not only is it the
perfect hearty tipple to wash down a
couple of oysters
it works its magic in soups stews pies
and cakes too
[Music]
suet a classic english ingredient since
the middle ages
this hard waxy fat is taken from around
the kidneys and loins
of beef or mutton today
sued is still prized for imparting a
unique lightness and rich
but subtle flavor to savory and sweet
steamed puddings
and today i'll be rolling up traditional
mustard suet dumplings
to hearty up a slow cooked beef stew
[Music]
ginger a zingy and versatile medicinal
and culinary
used powdered it adds punch to cakes
biscuits and beer
crystallized is eaten as lip smacking
sweet meat
and the fresh or pickled fibrous root
adds vibrant heat to dishes the length
and breadth of asia
i'll be using a triple ginger measure to
give depth and spice to wonderful
classic
pear and ginger galette
[Music]
when it comes to my ultimate hearty
lunch it's got to be soup soups can be
light
and delicate or rich and gutsy they're
versatile practical
and easy to make and for my ultimate
hearty lunch
i'm making one of my childhood favorites
roasted tomato soup
beautiful vine tomatoes the riper the
tomatoes the better the soup
take the core out get your thumb and
place it half a centimetre underneath
the tip of your knife
place it in and then just twist around
that's the only part of the tomato that
we're not using
red onion and garlic red onion because
it's sweeter than a white onion slice
your onions
and your garlic nice and fine
traditionally be making it in a pot
it's so much better to start it off on
top of the stove searing the tomatoes
and the garlic
when it goes in the oven you actually
roast the tomatoes and they don't stew
there's a big difference in flavor be
quite generous with the olive oil
it makes the soup nice and glossy shiny
salt
pepper and then a little teaspoon of
cayenne
just gives it that heat but it's not as
fierce as chili
take your tomatoes and just slice them
in half
and then a little touch of sugar that's
going to help
intensify the sweetness a little
sprinkle of aged bottled vinegar
gives that nice dark rich acidity
to the soup into the oven
20 25 minutes 180.
to make my soup even more irresistible
i'm going to make a punchy sun-dried
tomato pesto to drizzle over the top
now i'm making this in a pestle and
mortar because you feel
so much more in control and you're not
depending on a blade that's whizzing
around at a thousand miles an hour
next in a dry pan toast off some pine
nuts
toast them the absolute max and then in
the smell in there is incredible
parmesan lightly grate that
this is where it starts to become creamy
extra virgin olive oil
doesn't need salt because the parmesan
is going to season it for you
and just take a couple tablespoons of
the oil the sun-dried tomatoes are in
really helps to make that stunning pesto
i can smell those roasted tomatoes want
them out
wow
next pour in a little vegetable stock or
chicken stock so it sits halfway up the
tomatoes
put your spoon through those tomatoes
they break up instantly
bring that up to the boil let it simmer
for three or four minutes
i want to make a little bit more creamy
now cream in
give that a little stir you can keep it
rustic and you get your masher in
and you've got that nice thick rich
chunky
tomato soup or get yourself a stick
blender
blitzing it like that you delays the
bottom of the pan and you get all those
amazing flavors from the bottom
that's delicious to make my lunch extra
hearty
i'm gonna knock up a deliciously gutsy
version of cheese on toast to go with my
tomato soup
whilst we have it an absolute classic
i'm gonna make a roux
50 grams of butter three nice
tablespoons of flour
and that's all there is basically
traditionally you would use
flour butter and milk but in welsh
rabbit the milk is often cheekily
substituted
for a stiff slug of stout gives it that
strong
gutsy flavor
i want it nice and thick make sure those
lumps are out
a nice teaspoon of dijon mustard and
then season it
nice and spicy moisture sauce gives it
that delicious
intriguing flavor now that smells
amazing
almost brings tears to your eyes
beautiful
now boss rabbit wouldn't be a stunning
welsh rabbit without rich
mature cheese soap and a great
montgomery cheddar goes well with the
beer
and drop that in really important to put
this in while the roux
is still nice and hot because the cheese
melts
now for the bread i prefer a good rustic
country loaf that will stand up to my
hardcore topping
i want that nice crisp base to my welsh
rabbit
so toast it both sides
[Music]
spread that beautiful cheesy berry spicy
mixture
just great got a blister
and bubble and gratinate
god a little splash
alien perry and back under the grill for
90 seconds
in one delicious creamy roasted
tomato soup it's coming back to me all
those days i had off school
i used to purposely lie about feeling
ill just to get a bowl of my mother's
tomato soup
how bad was that but my god it was worth
it
now i'll welsh rabbit
[Music]
look at those babies that just takes
cheese on toast
to another level wow
roasted creamy tomato soup with a
sun-dried tomato pesto
served with the most amazing delicious
welsh rabbit i feel like ringing in sick
[Music]
some of the best hearty dinners i can
think of are slow cooked
recipes made with robust deep flavoured
ingredients and
left to bubble away for hours until they
become glossly rich
this is the sort of food that really
gives you plenty of energy and protects
you against cold winter weather
so for my ultimate hearty dinner i'm
doing a dish that every home cook
should have a recipe before a great
stick to your rib stew
here's my favorite beef and ale with
mustard dumplings
[Music]
and helping in the kitchen is my
youngest tilly
[Music]
tilly first things first i'd like you to
season the stewing steak
a nice spoon of flour
yeah good girl what's the flower going
to do dad
the flower helps to brown the beef our
seasoned flour will also help to add
flavor
and thicken the stew i feel a bit like
marshmallows they do feel
a little bit marshmallow don't they look
at the size of the chunks of the beef
i'm going to cut my carrots literally be
similar
similar size that's right does that mean
they'll cook equally that's right
now these are little pearl onions i'm
going to put them in hole as well
everything has to stay the same
otherwise it could burn oh we've seen
burned garlic before
oh matilda she promised you weren't
going to mention that
what was that time
time and what are they bay leaves
bailey's good girl
a tablespoon of oil in the beef goes in
first
okay in
a really nice color got a beautiful
color
remember the carrots thyme in good go
garlic pearl onions in
good give that a really good mix up
[Music]
easy to make daddy stews are very easy
to make
providing at the beginning you give it a
little bit of love
now that's all beautifully browned
that bin that is beer and that's going
to deglaze the pan
adding beer or stout helps to tenderize
the beef and give it a hearty delicious
flavor
and that's the only way i want you to
taste beer
in a stew yeah
i want to add in a couple of teaspoons
of tomato puree please
in fact three please because it's so
nice and there's one final thing in
there
cover the steering state with the bee
stock give that a little mix with daddy
please
wow that's really nice it's not even
cooked yet do you keep all these
vegetables
in when you um serve it to people oh yes
is the garlic going to be burnt
excuse me right and we always put the
lid
with a little bit just a little bit so
it can breathe that's right
not make the stew all watery into the
oven at 150 please tails for about two
and a half hours
and now you can focus on your homework
fun
time to knock up two delicious hearty
potato classics in one
twice baked bubble and sweet jacket
potatoes
start by baking large potatoes in a
preheated oven at 180 degrees
shred one third of your savoy cabbage
and saute in butter and add a dash of
water until tender
[Music]
after about half an hour your potatoes
should be crisp on the outside
and cook through in the middle slice
them in half
and scoop out the soft potato center
then mash with a couple of knobs of
butter
mix in the cabbage and season to taste
spoon this mixture back into your potato
shells and into the oven for a further
10 minutes
or until the tops are nice and crispy
and golden
two delicious hearty potato classics in
one twice baked bubbling squeak
jacket potatoes right homework done
yep beef juice chewing stewing let's get
on with our delicious
hearty pet art i've been looking forward
to this
you and i chef i'm gonna prep the pears
so if you peel
i'll top and tail into quarters pears go
soft in the oven very very quickly
so we're going to put them on a tart
you'll need to leave them whole half or
in quarter
what's that in there ginger that's right
a stem ginger so you stem ginger and
fresh ginger
next add your stem ginger a little of
the stem ginger syrup
good girl and some brown sugar to your
quartered pears
and then just grab some fresh ginger off
you go
so it's a bit of a different one to
grate this
because it doesn't really come through
like the cheese
no i'm gonna make that a little bit
zesty now we've got some lemons
some lemon zest in there right what we
need to do now
is give that a nice little mix
now this is a sweet pastry you can buy
this stuff where you make it it's so
easy to do
so give me your finger that's my center
point i want you to get
the pears going around like that
a really nice circle it's difficult
isn't it because the pairs keep on
sliding all over the place
yeah so egg wash the outside and i'm
going to show you a little trick
so you lift that up so the egg wash
acting like a bit of a glue
that's right crimple this with our
finger
and the pastry forms this nice little
shelf like a little money bag
are you going to do anything with the
spare pears oh yeah
you start building that up then you see
the fresh ginger
and those nice little bits of stem
ginger let me go around mike
with your glue we might glue just on top
tilly's last job is to give our tart a
good dusting of icing sugar
so that caramelizes it and colors the
pears beautifully
it's a bit like snow isn't it now that
glaze is a pastry so the pastry has this
really nice shine on there as well
finally the lemon on top and then put
that there
180 and in she goes
you smell the beef smells delish
wow it's even gone down a bit more
hasn't it look at that
i want you to just i was hoping you'd
ask
just have a little taste
[Music]
how's that taste now i'm not allowed
anymore
dumpling time flour in please i'm using
self-raising flour
for a fluffy result but if you like your
dumplings hard
use plain flour next the dumpling
essential
suet that makes the dumplings nice and
moist
thank you followed by a generous dollop
of grain mustard
two fingers start rolling the fingers
round
and i've got a touch of warm water here
your fingers are now
a nice little whisk my fingers are
getting tired all right now put your
hand in there now you should bring
all that dough together i'll show you
the best way to get that nice and clean
sprinkle some flour on your hands rub
them together
all that will come off that's a good way
isn't it now you've got this wonderful
dumpling mixture
how squidgy is that a little flower
on your hands okay roll these lengthways
and then i want you to fall in like that
in your hand
off we go smell that mustard in there
huh come on he'd
never trust you with something like that
yes please silly
gently let's go in at 12 o'clock
one o'clock 12 in the center put that
back into the oven
for 20 minutes to cook the dumplings now
if you open the door for daddy i'm going
to take out that tart
oh it smells so nice doesn't it
our pet art has had 35 minutes in the
oven
look at that baby that looks good
would you like me to start dusting yes
please nice and gently all the way
around
good girl little taps the others are
gonna love this it looks a bit like a
snowy cake
doesn't it good job now very carefully
carry that to the table how
nice does that look delicious okay i'll
check on the dumplings
now look they've sort of doubled in size
whoa definitely a final sprinkle of
chopped parsley and our stew is ready
for the table
i might have to have a quick taste
before we go
just to check i mean we don't have to be
sure
we have to be very sure
[Music]
hmm that is an amazing hearty beef stew
with dumplings right
the twice baked loaded potatoes and we
are ready
this is my ultimate hearty dinner a
comforting rich beef stew with mustard
dumplings
and twice baked bubbling squeak jacket
potatoes
and to make sure your sweet tooth is
completely satisfied
a rich and zingy pear and ginger galette
let's go holly are you ready for some
delicious
beef stew yeah oh wow thank you very
much
delicious thank you
we'll be able to heat this up for mum
and jack when they come back
easy even two or three days later tasty
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app
cook with me you can find it in the app
store good luck
you